my name is karen crock
and i came here because i was
just really tired very low energy had a
hard time functioning
and concentrating at work um
dr berg did the um some
pressure techniques i don't know what
they're called
but i just felt so relaxed and so good
and i went home and went straight to
sleep and just had a really good night's
rest afterwards
i really didn't know what to expect i
thought
i'd give it a try i had seen several dr
berg's talks and
he seemed very knowledgeable so i
thought i'd give it a try
i would start telling him some symptoms
i had and then he would say oh and do
you have this this and this i'm like yes
how did you know
so i mean he was really good about
i think figuring out as soon as i
started describing some things
i think he understood because then he
could tell me back
things i didn't even think were related
like i had cold feet and i just thought
it was because i was cold out
and he's like well yeah that's a symptom
of
something the adrenal gland problem or
something i forget
i like to avoid taking pills and taking
traditional medicine i guess so i really
like this
alternate much better so if i can feel
better by
eating a lot more kale and a lot more
cruciferous
however you say that eating more
vegetables if i can do that instead of
taking pills i'd much rather do that
my main thing was energy i really didn't
have a
weight problem but i do feel like i have
more energy
i mean when i first came
i remember going to a yoga class and
going home and just falling asleep
because yoga wore me out
which is not a strenuous activity and
so i've been able to do yoga classes now
and i feel good and
i just i feel like i have a lot more
energy to be able to do things now